give it your best so one of the things
that I'm super passionate about is when
you are putting your effort your energy
your hustle your harder than something
that you really give it your best that
you really figure out what it is that
you are so deeply strongly committed to
that you want to put in the hustle put
in the effort so that when you create it
it's something you can be proud of and I
think too many people mail it in too
many people have an idea that they don't
commit themselves fully to and you don't
get the results they want and then they
live with regret that five years later
ten years later maybe they're back at
some job instead of betting on
themselves and certain their own company
and they say you know what if I if I
just pushed a little bit harder if I
just gave it a little bit more if I
didn't just do the bare minimum me piya
would have been more successful and that
that's what haunts me that's what I'm
scared of that's what fuels me because I
don't want a feel like the projects that
I really care about that i want to
create to have an impact on this world
that I mailed it in and that I could
have pushed a little bit harder to make
it better and so how relates to my book
when I was writing the book I had that
consciously in the back of my head that
this has to be something that is super
powerful and that I am putting
everything I have into which is why I
ended up writing two books and you know
the length of two books in half of it
got cut to get put into this book but
it's still coming up and this this is
relevant today because I was recording
videos for the people who bought the
books for me will buy a book they get a
bonus video where I make a quick thank
you video thanking them for their
support and it's super humbling
appreciative and I love seeing like
every individual steal that comes in
means a lot to me and so one of the
people who ordered the book Stephen
Moton or Martin from Florida sorry for
the mispronunciation Stephen Stephen
bought five copies of my audiobook and
he bought one for himself and for two
gift to his friends and family and so I
was really inspired by that because I'm
starting to record the audio book next
month
there's 313 mondays in October where
have to sit down and record the audio
book it's not done yet the book is done
but the audio book has to be recorded
and I told Stephen I'm going to be
channeling him when I'm gonna go record
the audio because I want it to be
something that I am really proud of and
that I'm giving it my all you know what
let's play the clip I'm going to play
the clip that I made the video for for
Stephen hopefully you can feel the
energy in the pride that I made in that
thank you video Stephen happy Wednesday
my man wanted to say thank you for
buying five copies of my book really
means a lot to me and super excited to
get your feedback when it does come out
I love that you bought some copies to
your friends and family in and the
e-book is going to be exciting that I
just secured the time to go out and
record it so I got it I got three or
four Monday's in October next month that
I am going to go to studio and record
and while i'm sitting in recording I'm
channeling Stephen and I'm thinking man
Stephen he went out he got it for
himself his family gotta deliver on this
audio for you man um anyway super Krete
the support i don't know where lake land
is in florida i'm in florida pretty much
every year because i think my son to
disney world and i love watching my Blue
Jays in spring training so we're there
in March to every year um it's wednesday
i'm about to head into filming my videos
for the week but wanted to just quickly
take a time out to say thank you really
appreciate the support man that's it
have a great week continue to believe or
whatever your one word is I'll see the
students email so hopefully you feel the
energy you feel the excitement you feel
the passion I have I want you to bring
that to what you're doing right like
look at the work that you're doing the
videos you're creating the products
you're creating the service you're
providing to your customers are you
giving it at all are you leaving stuff
on the table are you just kind of
mailing in a little bit not that you're
giving a bad job obviously if you do a
bad job you're not going to get customs
coming back but could you do a little
bit more that product that you're
releasing could it be a little bit
better because if it doesn't work out if
you've left it all out on the field if
you've done your very best that you can
do right now yes you might be able to
learn new skills yes you may be able to
get better with more practice but where
you're at right now with the
resources you have with the skills that
you have the knowledge that you have the
wisdom that you have what you create it
is that the very best thing you could do
because if you put that out and it
doesn't work I can live with that you
should be able to live with that like I
put a ton of love into this book if it
doesn't work I can live with it but if
it doesn't work and i know i could have
done a little bit more if it doesn't
work and you know you could put a little
bit more effort or even if it does work
and you know you could have put a little
bit more you're always going to live
with that regret for the rest of your
life wondering what if what if i put in
that little bit extra drive what if i
was just insanely proud with that
product i created that i could make
anything better than what i launched
that what if will kill you is what
drives me to create the very best
content the very best products and
services that i can and hopefully drives
you to so first off I wanna get to the
book tallies we are sitting at 161 sales
out of 3,000 so we have crossed the five
percent mark which is a good start but
we got to get more so for those you
watching you know really appreciate the
support I think the bonuses obviously
have a lot of value you know hopefully
you're feeling the passion that went
into the book and it's not just about
selling a book to try to make a lot of
money and you know get my name out there
like I truly believe that the content in
this book will have immeasurable results
on your business and your life like its
helped me so much and helped the
concepts in the book of help the people
around me so much that I just honestly
can't wait to get it in your hands in
and just see just see what happens just
see the explosion to see the growth you
know I'm at a loss of words just
overcome with the joy and excitement and
optimism i have for when people actually
open it up and read it the impact that
it's going to have on them so we're at
160 why we still have a lot of time to
go I know it's still december six that
it's coming out we're now just a set of
September but every order I really
appreciate if you guys are thinking
about gift buying and spreading the word
and trying to help some entrepreneurs
and friends of yours then we appreciate
the support and now let's get to the
questions
or stop Erica d I really can't wait for
the book I really can't wait to somebody
actually wrote to me who bought the book
and said is this part of your sales
technique or you know marketing strategy
to delay the launch and they already
bought the book to the supporter it's
really not in my hands this is the this
is like dealing with a publisher I
wanted the book as soon as possible like
I wrote the book Oh super happy with it
we've made a few minor changes in the
past couple months but like I wanted it
out and they wanted to come out in
january and i don't really get
everything that has to happen for
publishers to move i think part of you
know they have a process and in all
honesty you know the process could be a
lot smoother a lot faster than a lot of
the industry is broken but we push for
december thanks to your feedback as well
because i wanted like this year that
it's let's go I want it out I wanted in
people's hands I wanted you know
changing lives having an impact and so
it's not it's not a marketing trick or
sales strategy or anything this is the
actual date that was given by the
publisher if I could get it to you guys
sooner I would it is just not available
like I have some pre order copies but
that's it like I don't even have there's
no secret room full of books that I can
go to and pull one out and give it to
you I don't have them they don't exist
yet and so december six Izzy is the
actual date where like I'm getting it
too so I feel the frustration i love the
frustration like i love that you guys
looking forward to it i am too we're all
frustrated together you know december
six hopefully is a big celebration a big
party when you guys i'll get the books
next up a rest day 2013 i pre-ordered
the book thank you for that bro how
where can I contact evan for the
shoutout and to get the bonuses thanks
in advance so for that the email address
is on the the book landing page was one
word ever chemical calm just forward
your receipt on to their you'll get a
video i think i actually record looking
at your picture i think i made their
video already for you this morning so
that should be in your inbox but also
the chance that a shout-out really
depends on the quantity a book so if
you're ordering multiple books you have
a much higher chance of getting a shout
out faster on the channel then if it's
just one book if it's one book your kind
of entered into a draw and hopefully
your name shows up but
yeah email one were to ever come real
calm and we'll get the bonuses to you
and if you don't get the bonus and make
sure to follow up because it should be
within within 24 hours that you get it
next up Antoine thanks for the shadow
and congrats on reaching 400,000 subs
bro sorry i haven't been commenting
there watching much of your videos
lately but my Hustle is real here my
book got released and as both the
publisher and the author i have to send
it out as a real nightmare good thing i
love challenge ain't wanna know is a
fellow canadian from quebec and also
bought one of the books so i'm super
appreciative of that Antoine a couple
things one thank you for the 400 k
shoutout I know a number of you have
mentioned that in the comments and I'm
super preciate of that I was you know at
home watching it kind of ticked down and
then the next day I loaded my my
subscriber base like a loaded up YouTube
and Wow 400,000 and it's great it's a
good milestone it's nice to have I think
half a million and really million is the
next milestone million i get my my new
plaque I got 200,000 plaque here and I
want to get I want to get the million
but yeah you're right i'm like it's not
it's not the big goal for me it's not
the big motivator for me i don't make
videos only to get 100,000 subs or
million subs i make it because i want to
try to have an impact and hopefully
you're making the processor with you
guys create because you want to have an
impact if you're not watching the videos
i get it like i would much rather you
guys are out executing than just
watching every single video i made a
video that will link up that said you
don't need to watch every one of my
videos it came from a rant in one of
these book videos before where i get it
i'm putting out you know three to four
videos a day i believe that they are all
instrumental in helping you build a
better business and honestly and
becoming a better person I put out
videos that i like and i resonate with
and I've grown from an I've learned
about myself and that motivate me
everything is through my eyes right like
that's how I your YouTube channel is how
I see the world and the lesson that I've
learned from these successful people but
if you can't keep up or you're off
executing or whatever I get it I'm not
upset I appreciate the love when you
guys come i love the comments i love it
when you share you guys fuel me i look
at the comments every day but if you're
so busy out executing and hustling on
your job and your idea and you don't
need the extra drive and motivation
inspiration go do it like I'm happy for
you that's the intent I don't want you
just sitting on YouTube all day I want
you going out and chasing your dreams
and better in the world in some way so
no need to apologize man when you're
here I love it I greatly appreciate it
hopefully you gain something thank you
for contributing back to believe Nation
leaving some comments being a force for
good and and that's for all of you like
the time you spend on my channel I
greatly appreciate it and especially
those you who are commenting and not
just commenting for me but to each other
and helping each other out and sharing
ideas and wisdom that means a lot but
it's interesting how we've been will
bring together people who never knew
each other before and they now they have
a support system from around the world
and i love that we could bring that
together for your book super excited hit
me up man i want to know what the book
is about I maybe we could do something I
you know supporting someone in believe
nation and somebody period the book and
somebody was trying to help
entrepreneurs out to let me know cuz cuz
maybe we can do something together so
we'll leave that I'll check my email no
you got it and yeah I'm excited for you
and good luck with that process next up
is mono pretty great work Evan thanks
bro I've been looking forward to this
all year I me too man that really means
a lot I've just pre-ordered the
audiobook inaudible and have a hard copy
on amazon UK i notice the audible states
that the narrator is to be confirmed
will you be narrating this please say
yes all caps or maybe just the opening
closing chapters like Arnold
Schwarzenegger doing with Total Recall
thumbs up so I talked about this a
number of times in previous book videos
but yes the audio version is confirmed
thank you for ordering the audio book
online it really means a lot and I am
doing the audio version I insisted on it
I probably would have helped back like
if I couldn't read it I probably
wouldn't have bail out for there to be
an audio version but there's no reason
why the publisher wouldn't want me to do
it too right I get that a lot of authors
there either they're either not good at
reading or they just don't want to put
in the hustle right they don't want to
do the extra work right let somebody
else read that I don't want to read it
which to me back to the top right the
the theme of this video of making
something that you're really passionate
about putting in the work I didn't want
to mail it in like this is such an
important book not just for me but for
or for you guys that I don't think
anybody else could read my message the
way that I could read it I'm so fired up
about doing it I'm so excited and so I
have to do it fortunately the publisher
said yes I'm going to be recording it as
I mentioned earlier in October and I
can't wait I can't wait to get in the
studio I can't wait to I just can't wait
I'm so pumping I thank you for that note
because i'm gonna i'm gonna forward that
to my publisher and let them know that
I'm not listed as the narrator so that
hopefully we can get that change I
really appreciate I mean you guys are
noticing things that look funny or
strange or incongruent let me know
because I will notify the publisher and
hopefully we can make changes for you
guys next up new future builder I hope
someone does put down for the 500 books
too if I had the resources i definitely
would haven't read it yet obviously but
i'm sure it can change some lives and i
would love to donate it to those that
need it really appreciate that man I
think there's insane value at every
level I think if you buy one book I
think the bonuses alone cover the price
and you get this amazing book that will
help I think if you're buying 10 books
10 books costs uh like just under 200
bucks I think if I've added two hundred
dollars of value to you guys in the
videos over the how many months or years
you've been following me instead of
signing up for somebody's coaching
program if the free videos i put it out
have helped you then I would love for
you guys consider buying ten books or
more you know the 50 100 500 um but I
get I get it like if you don't have the
resources you're not in that spot right
now I appreciate the single orders I
appreciate the two orders I appreciate
the five orders I appreciate the zero
orders where you're just even a positive
comment you know like if 19 bucks is out
of your control right now because you're
struggling to pay the internet bills I
get that and watching this video means a
lot to me and liking it and sharing it
means a lot to me too so I don't want to
just like guilt people into feeling bad
for not ordering the book I appreciate
every human being that is part of
believe nation in to the extent that you
can support me and help me what I'm
doing as well as support the people
around you with with gift in the book
I'm just overwhelmingly appreciative and
and I thank you for your support next up
Zeno I know it wasn't really a milestone
for you but congratulation for
subscribers thank you bro hopefully on a
book will be available somewhere where
you don't need a credit card looking
forward to either reading or listening
to the book or both and of course
applying it also Jason came out to play
yeah still getting the Jason comments
this is still not it's still not back
but next week I think Jason's box will
be filming from Toronto dance salsa
studios I don't know what the processes
are for the audio book again I talked
about it before the publishers don't do
pre-releases of audio books it's not
industry practice and so for the
hardcover we can get it multiple layers
you can get it on Amazon you can get it
at barnes a noble you can get it at a
whole like anywhere they sell books you
can get the the book but for the
audiobook we had to make it a special
exception with the publisher reaching
out to say hey we need to get this going
a little faster and so the only the only
company that's agreed to it is audible
now luckily it's audible it's you know
one of the biggest is with amazon so
there's an option for you guys you will
go and get it the other ones we haven't
been able to convince yet to move their
traditional processes along if you guys
have noticed a change and let me know
even the audible one I didn't know until
one of you guys bought it from audible
so at least there's that option there
hopefully more people open up so that
you can find you have some variety you
can buy it wherever you want to buy it's
however they like the payment doesn't
come to me right I'm not collecting the
payment then giving it to whatever
company they collect the payment so
however however they collect payment
that's how it is so if it's not if they
have a non credit card option fingers
crossed that somebody will open that up
next up Eric Sanchez first
congratulations on the 400 k subs much
love Eric I've learned to get more value
you have to give more than what is
expected in product sales you give then
set product and extra bonuses as well as
the best service they have ever had no
matter if they are spending a few
dollars to a few thousand in a
service-based industry you have to treat
them like they're a family on top of
just finding or giving them the best
deals on a service simply put you have
to care about them and show it that's my
take on value great video Evan keep up
the amazing work hashtag believe nation
hashtag BTA 29 listen Erica I agree you
know right now just as an example for
everybody who's buying the book I make a
video for them so somebody is spin
dane 19 bucks to get an audio Booker to
get the hardcover book I will sit down
and make a video and send it to them now
i'm not i'm making almost nothing off of
it right i don't know what the royalties
are I'm not making when you spend
nineteen dollars on a book it's not
coming to me I get like a percent or
percent and a half or whatever I haven't
even looked at the agreement like money
is not the reason why I'm doing it but I
will still sit down and make a video for
you and I've done how many videos a
hundred how many sales we have what did
I say 161 now some of those are multiple
orders but I've done over a hundred
videos now already thinking people for
their order that is not worth the time
for me if I calculate how much I would
charge an hour compared to how much I'm
making it's so far below minimum wage
that doesn't make sense but it's just
the right thing to do I love you guys I
appreciate the support I you know the
steven is buying five books to the
Tamara's buying ten books to the people
who buy one book you know the people who
might buy more books I appreciate
everybody and I try to at every level if
you want to have success in business you
have to over-deliver on the value to
feel like I'm getting way more than what
I paid for because I want people to have
so much value and just what they get
that when the book comes it's a bonus
with a book itself is worth so much more
like the book itself is so amazing and
then if you apply the lessons in there
watching your life transformed and
explode i'm so excited genuinely them to
see you guys go out and make changes
after you reading the ply what's in the
book but I get that as far away and I
want to make sure the bonus is alone
offer the value and so I know you guys
are talking about you know somebody
ordering fire on your books or hundred
books and if that happens it's amazing
and the value is there for the personal
coaching and access to my look I would
never sell I don't sell personal
coaching it's not part of my business
model I don't want to be a coach because
the value of helping one person versus
be able to help all you guys doesn't pay
off for me so the only time I'm doing
coaching is through this book offer the
access to me an email where you get
access to me for a month or multiple
months it's not worth my time like in
terms of my big goals in the value that
I want to do so all the stuff that I'm
doing is not worth it
it's not worth the time but I do it
because I just feel it's the right thing
to do because I really humbly appreciate
your support because you guys mean a lot
to me and and I want to see I want you
feeling like you got way more value than
than what you paid for and and that will
come back I know it'll come back not
with everybody but the people who really
value it it'll come back so much more
than the time that I invested into it
that it's always worked like that for me
and I'll always continue to do it even
though logically it doesn't make any
sense another one from mono pretty mana
pretty polly monopoly monopoly I
remember earlier in the year you were
looking for ideas for incentives for
people to pre-order the book I suggested
signed copies with a personal message
but your idea of a video message is even
better my humble opinion and something
that I would never have thought of great
job thank you i can't actually take
credit for that with someone on my team
brent who we were looking at the
different bonus packages and you guys
were so instrumental helpful coming up
with different ideas and we had to pare
it down to figure out okay like let's
have five different packages for people
because if we have 30 different packages
just overwhelming and too confusing and
my base level access i think was ten
books where you get to ask me a question
ask me any question you want you buy ten
books ask me a question and i will make
a video response for you to try to help
you whatever problem you have i will
spend the time to sit down and make a
video to respond and that's still in the
10 book package for people who have
questions but brent said it would be
great to be able to have access to you
at one book because people love paying
for access and I thought that's really
interesting what can I do like if we
sell thousands of books how am I going
to be able to do this it's a lot of time
and so I thought you know what just a
quick thank you video and the random
shout outs so at the end of every video
is a random shout out the people who buy
more you have more odds of being able to
get a shout out so not everybody will
get a shadow because we're selling more
books than then we have videos for but
also I make a thank you video and and
today I made I don't know 20 25
different Thank You videos for people
who have bought the books and it's me
talking for 30 seconds or whatever just
like you saw earlier on in the show the
one that I made for Stephen
that's what I do that's what I make for
for everybody who buys the book and so I
love that idea of having access to me at
some point other words it's an insane
commitment to do i don't know if i'll do
it after the launch like once december
six comes out and i don't know if i'll
do it for future books but for now it
feels right and so i'm gonna keep doing
it and I'm glad that you guys are
enjoying it and the response and those
videos has been amazing I think that's
also partly why people see the videos
and they're freaking out that i made a
video for them and the message that i
had in there and they feel more
connected and like just seeing that
response makes me feel like yeah like
it's a huge amount of time invested but
it's worth it because i like seeing the
smiles and the impact that attack next
up eric i went near the king of adding
value really appreciate that Eric admire
your dedication to pose two or three
excellent new videos a day thank you a
couple quick thoughts that come around
that first is yes it's a massive grind
for me it's a lot of work it's been like
that for years where we've been posting
multiple videos it started at one video
a week and then one video a day and now
two videos a day now three videos a day
and sometimes four videos a day it's the
grind that I love it's the thing that I
love doing Jerry Seinfeld in one of our
Clips was talking about you have to find
the torture that you can live with
something like that I think a lot of
people jumping into my role would see
this torture like this is way too much
work making I can't make one video a
week how am I gonna do three or four a
day and I just like it's a grind that I
love where I'm sure if I stepped into
your job I would hate a lot of the stuff
you're doing and would would die but I
love this and so finally the thing that
you love and being consistent at it is
super important I'm glad that you're
you're feeling it I'm glad you're
getting that you're getting value from
it and the dedication is what keeps you
through like in my early days I wasn't
getting comments and tons of views but
consistency consistency consistency and
it's applicable to whatever you want to
be a singer you want to be a good
gardener you want to be you know a good
programmer you have to be consistent you
gotta dedicate yourself you won't learn
enough in the 24-hour period like you
got to keep grinding but the key is to
find the thing that the grind doesn't
feel like work the grind is something
that you're addicted to the grind is
something that you enjoy doing you're
not just targeting the end goal but
you like the process of getting to that
ankle next up is Christ durden this is
such a great idea i'm trying to get more
exposure for my books already released
can you give me more advice I use
everything from all the videos you post
thank you for that super appreciative a
couple ideas that I'm using and you
hopefully that has an impact for you one
is showing the behind the scene so this
video series we're like 60 something
episodes in it's over a year's worth of
content I've been taking people on the
journey answering questions being you
know they're being a part of my growth
and learning how I'm doing things and it
allows you to talk about your books
without it being promotion all the time
right like I've shown some passion
hopefully you guys watch it and you know
are interested enough and go out and buy
some of the books but it's not always
just go by the book is the best thing
ever you know is creating content around
this so what can you what kind of
content can you create around your book
that makes it interesting for people can
you show behind the scenes stuff can you
relate your book to something that's
happening in the world right now some of
the things I'm doing as well as reading
pages from the book my book and other
people's books is a new book video
series hashtag book videos where's
basically excerpts from the book and
making those into videos so how can you
create content I notice your YouTube
channel doesn't have subscribers I don't
know if you have any videos or not on
there but whether video is your
mechanism or you know you'd like writing
so you create a blog around it you need
to have content around that helps
promote it the second thing I would look
at is using influencers so what kind of
audiences your book serve how can you
connect with people who have influence
to that audience and introduce your book
to that influencer and if they like it
then they'll share it with their
audience I think it's a huge opportunity
for you whatever whatever your book
topics are covering and as well is there
is there anything relevant in the media
that you can relate back to the book I
don't know if it's fiction nonfiction
what you're writing about but is their
story in the book that relates to
something that's going on right now that
you can provide commentary on because
every time is a article written they
need an expert to talk about it and why
can't that expert vu so good luck I'm
excited for you next up ecar oh hey
Michael it's Evan bro and not Michaels
Evan I'm 20 years old in Nigeria I want
to be a motivational speaker been
reading books watching videos learning
from other
is that I've gone ahead of us I don't
know how to start my motivational career
you please guide me so a couple things
ones just start let me see the other
youtube channel hovering over your name
one subscriber so make videos one the
quantity will lead to quality practice
you got to get better most of my gates
opportunities engagements come from my
youtube channel because i'm dedicated
there because when creating content
because i made over 3,000 videos because
every time I make a video I get better
like this video me and speaking is
better than than my first Evans book
video that I launched 60 whatever weeks
ago I get better hopefully every time I
make a video you will get better too so
if you want to be a motivational speaker
you have to practice your craft you got
to get really good at it by making
videos that's the first step and that
gives you awareness and attention you
have a video that's really good it'll
spread people will share it like if
you're upset that people aren't sharing
your videos well maybe your video wasn't
good enough like that's probably the
case it's not about marketing the better
it's just people watched it and they
didn't want to share it so it's not good
enough but still a challenge I face I
look at my videos and then we'll see how
can I market better how can I do a
better job getting out there really the
video just needs to get better like I
still need to get better i have 400,000
subs it's still small in the YouTube
world I'm not the king of anything yet
right I need to keep making these videos
consistently better and you do to tie it
along to that I'd be looking at how do I
get in person engagements for free
volunteer but build a name for yourself
I did it out of the ymca in my local
community so you practice and you get
better and people watching they can't
wait for your next thing and you get
better as well and your skills and
presenting and the topics that you're
covering ishing that works and what
doesn't work to the point where you want
your name to be spread you must have you
seen this person speaking got it we've
got to get this person to come to speak
at our next event those two things
making YouTube channel be consistent
every day I want to see new video from
you to try to do once a week speaking at
some kind of event even for free and
three model success if you love my
videos great I'm humbled I'm honored by
that I would look at it Zig Ziglar and
Les Brown and Tony Robbins and Jack Hank
field and all the people that you look
up to study them research them before
doing every wednesday so I'm recording
this on a Wednesday
I sit down and in what I'm saying that
but I do it I record all afternoon for
the week for my youtube channel in the
morning this morning I do my morning run
while listening to Les Brown on
Wednesdays because he's a speaker he has
a coaching program on how to be a better
speaker and a lot of the stuff I know
but it's good to reinforce and and I
want to have some of that kind of flow
through me as those reminders and so
surrounding yourself with that kind of
knowledge model and success can be a
third super helpful point as well next
up is mile hi Evan I can't wait to have
your book in my luggage and give me an
opportunity to time access anytime to
your ability simple fly complex ideas I
got much love i really feel that thank
you i watch your videos since i was
looking for strength to build my
business seller years ago because of
this i have shaped my creativity through
many informations i can get from your
contents the book one word has a huge
value for me as i don't have access to
internet when I'm on the road while I
need all the time to be stimulated this
was actually one of the main reasons why
I wanted to write a book one I felt like
the topics covered in this book lends
itself better to a book then videos just
the exercises that you have to go
through and the thinking is easier to
consume when you have it all in front of
you instead of having to go through a
video series I just felt it was better
in the book format but also to reach a
new audience and to reach people when
they are traveling or they don't have
access to internet but they can't watch
the videos my goal is to have impact and
that's why I wanted to write the book
and so I'm appreciative that that's
coming through on your own too next up
Malika I was really moved by the
sentence if you enjoyed the videos I've
given you for free and you want to help
out a little bit it would really mean a
lot to me so true as a faithful watcher
I know you deserve much more than 3,000
copies I'm not financial possibility now
the buy it but i believe soon that I
will so I just wanted you to know there
are a lot of us for sure who support you
and will be happy to help you reach your
goal soon Evan all the best you and your
team PS your expresso song is my alarm
saw you know I'm talking about this but
I want to bring it up again because I
feel that the love honestly that that's
good too right like i don't i don't like
idiot putting people down because they
can't didn't buy the book because
they're not in a financial position to
do it i understand that that not
everybody's in this situation I get
if you can afford it and I've had any a
meaningful impact on your life somehow
I've made you think the videos have
helped you you know if you went to
university or went to any other course
training to learn this stuff from the
best people in the world you know it
cost hundreds of thousands of dollars
and you get it for free on the YouTube
channel but like if you cannot afford it
I get it it's the the the heartfelt
comment makes me feel great thank you
for the comment thank you for if you
can't afford it thank you for sharing it
on your social media telling friends
about it leave in the comment being nice
for the people and believe nation if you
want to give back and you want to show
your appreciation if I had an impact
somehow in your life and your business
really it's doing what you can't like if
you built a multimillion-dollar business
off of the knowledge in my channel and
this really helped you then yeah you
should go on by 500 copies that helped
you a lot yeah but if you can't you
haven't made a lot of money yet or
you're still in the early stages you
can't afford it then sharing it on
social or leaving comments it still
means a lot like I hate the idea that
people might feel bad that they're not
able to support it to the extent like
they didn't buy a book where they bought
one they wanted by 10 another bought 10
but they wish they could buy 500 like
don't feel bad your support is so
meaningful to me and I'm so grateful and
that's why I still make the videos for
like every every single person buys a
book because I know that that was an
important decision for them and I'm just
so super appreciative so I get it I
understand you can't make that
commitment and I just feel so blessed
and love that that you would take the
time to write that comment for me so
thank you next up is mark grow a beard i
come again I got a little bit I got a
little bit of scrap happening here I did
have a beer before new future builders
right he also left a comment there about
my
wife is not a big fan of beards I like
it to a certain extent but once it gets
too big it's too itchy for me so here's
the thing I used to always be clean
shaven I used to always worry about what
other people would think I've never had
a meeting I would always make sure that
I shave and now I care a lot less care
about my wife's opinion I care about my
own opinion but I don't care but i'm
making this video a few guys i made all
my videos today for the channel for the
week without shaving I don't care like
if you're not going to watch my video
because I didn't shave then there's a
lot more wrong with you then with me if
I'm always super self-conscious of how I
look then then I won't deliver a quality
look if you're always worried about how
you look and what you're wearing then
you'll never be yourself and so I want
to focus on being myself so i might get
back to little bit shag your days but
again i'm not a huge fan because it does
h beyond a certain point so i can go
maybe a week maybe a week without
shaving but usually like five or six
days and then it's got come off next up
is sherry I don't know what happened but
you dropped off my subscription list
good thing I checked I'm buying shortly
i just want to say i faced some same
challenges I have customers who say no
one reads books anymore I totally
disagree I want the book in my hand so I
can reference it mark it up make notes
and grab it anytime I want without
digging through my computer looking for
the file surely every shortly i'll be
buying can't wait to read it she really
appreciate that support looking forward
to you you know buying it and uh and
reading it and getting into your hands
if you've already bought it thank you so
much really appreciate it two things
from the mind and watching this one yes
some people still love books some people
still love having a physical copy of a
book there's also people who want an
audiobook who want to just listen to it
while they're on the subway or while
they're working out or while they're
walking their dog while they're playing
pokemon go there's also some people who
want the e-book is a reading on their
tablet I think you know you want to be
where the people are and so for the
people who love the hardcover book it's
common it's a great gift you give other
people it's harder to gift a an e-book
version of it although steam is doing it
for the audiobook so I really appreciate
that the second thing that kind of was
just said at the beginning I think is
super interesting and helpful for you
guys watching I'm going to read it again
I don't know what happened but you
dropped you drop on my subscription list
good thing I checked so
sherry was a loyal viewer for a long
time and she stopped getting the feed i
guess in youtube or whatever i'm curious
for you guys think about the content you
create think about the news are you put
out and think about the videos you may
think about the tweets at your share and
think about the facebook poll think
about any content that you're making for
your business would people miss you if
you stop posting right what people
actually miss you and four ninety-five
percent of you i would prolly say no
would somebody like share it go the
extra route to say hey I didn't get this
person's newsletter I'm going to go find
out what happened right probably for you
it's not the same because the content
you're creating isn't good enough
because your newsletter are you kind of
mailing it in back to the topic right at
the top is maybe a good question end on
back to the topic at the top book really
put it in your all making it great it
applies to everything that you're doing
if people would not miss your newsletter
than your newsletter isn't very good
let's not really have the impact that it
should be having so I don't know why the
you know videos fell out of her feed but
I'm really glad that sherry wanted to go
in and spend the time to find me again
because the value that I'm creating is
high enough and for some people may not
be high enough like maybe our videos
still need to get better but it's a good
question to constantly ask yourself look
at the content you're creating name
across all your platforms your website
your blog your YouTube channel
everything that you're doing on a
consistent basis if it got pulled from
somebody's feed for some reason would
they make the effort to go back and
subscribe again to you because the value
you're providing is so overwhelmingly
amazing and for most of you is probably
no and that might be a good kick in the
pants to get on it and make something
that you're proud of so thank you for
joining me for this extended version of
the book I'm just feeling the love from
you guys so much we went like way over
what I normally do but I'm feeling
really blessed and warm today and and I
really have to run to get to my workout
class so that's it I need to give a
shout out who's a shadow to the shoutout
goes to
ooh gonzalo summit here Sam ETA Gonzalez
mbta hope I pronounced that ok thank you
so much water in my book really means a
lot to me if you guys watching
appreciate the love continue to believe
whatever your one word is and i will see
you soon